sergueï lavrov anthony blinken les chefs
de la diplomatie russe et américaine
réunis dans un hôtel de genève deux
heures de discussion avec au menu la
crise russo ukrainienne
notre objectif est de déterminer si la
russie est prête à emprunter la voie
diplomatique et à prendre d'autres
mesures nécessaires pour désamorcer la
situation en ukraine et en définitive
résoudre nos différends les discussions
d'aujourd'hui avec monsieur lavrov ont
été franches et substantielles
le dialogue n'est donc pas rompu alors
que washington considère de plus en plus
probable une incursion militaire russe
en ukraine moscou qui a déployé des
milliers de soldats à la frontière de
son voisin dément toute volonté
d'agression mais conditionne depuis le
début une désescalade ad traité
garantissant notamment le nom
élargissement de l'otan ce que refuse
catégoriquement les occidentaux à genève
sergueï lavrov et anthony blinken ont
toutefois convenu que washington
répondrait la semaine prochaine par
écrit à ses exigences je comprends
qu'ils aient leurs préoccupations mais
après nos explications ils ont compris
qu'ils devaient se concentrer sur le
fond sur l'essence de nos propositions
et une promesse nous a été faite je
tiens le raudière celle de nous apporter
une réponse écrite à nos propositions
dès la semaine prochaine ma seule piste
[Musique]
les deux diplomates ont rapporté avoir
convenu d'un nouveau contact à leur
niveau un sommet des deux président
vladimir poutine et jayden étant à ce
stade jugée prématurée